Hey Charles. How's it goin'?
>> It's going pretty well Michael. How are things going with you?
>> Good. You know I'm excited to tell you about neural networks today.
You may be familiar with neural networks because you have one, in your head.
>> I do?
>> Well, yeah. I mean, you have a network neurons. Like, you know,
you know neurons, like brain cells. Let me, let me, I'll draw you one.
>> Okay.
>> So this is my template drawing, a nerve cell,
a neuron. And you can, you know, you've got billions and
billions of these inside your head. And they have
you know, most of them have a pretty similar
structure, that there's the, there's the kind of the
main part of the cell called the cell body. And
then there's this thing called an axon which kind of is like a wire going
forward to a set of synapses which are kind of little gaps between
this neuron and some other neuron. And what happens is, information spike
trains
>> Woo woo!
>> Travel down the axon. When the
cell body fires it has an electrical impulse
it travels down the, the, the axon
and then causes across the synapses excitation to
occur on other neurons which themselves can
fire. Again by sending out spike trains. And
so they're very much a kind of
a computational unit and they're very, very complicated.
To a first approximation, as is often true with
first approximations they're very simple. Sort of by definition
of first approximation. So what, what, in the field
of artificial neural networks we have kind of a
cartoonish version of the neuron and networks of neurons
and we actually. Put them together to compute various
things. And one of the nice things about the,
the way that they're set up is that they
can be tuned or changed so that they fire under
different conditions and therefore compute different things. And they can
be trained through a learning process. So that's what we're
going to talk through if you haven't heard about this before.
>> Okay.
>> So we can replace this sort of detailed version of a
neuron with a very abstracted way kind of notion of a neuron.
And here's how it's going to work. We're going to have inputs
that are kind of you know, think of them as firing rates or
the strength of inputs. X1, X2, and X3 in this case. Those are
multiplied by weight, w1, w2, w3 correspondingly. And so the weights
kind of turn up the gain or the sensitivity of the neuron, this unit,
to each of the inputs respectively. Then what we're going to do is
we're going to sum them up. So we're going to sum. Over all the inputs.
The strength of the input times the weight,
and that's going to be the activation. Then
we're going to ask is that greater than,
or equal to the firing threshold. And if it
is, then we're going to say the output is one, and if it's not, we're going to
say the output is zero. So this is
a particular kind of neural net unit called Perceptron.
Which is a very sexy name because they had very sexy names in the 50s
>> They did.
>> When this was first developed. Alright?
So this, this whole neuron concept gets
boiled down to something much simpler, which is just, a linear sum followed by
a threshold, thresholding operation, right? So it's
worth kind of thinking, how can we,
what sort of things can this, can networks of these kinds of units compute? So,
let's see if we can figure some of those things out.